who do I model on YouTube I'm going to
answer that question in today's episode
of lunch and earn so I Risa got asked a
question for one of my YouTube friends
love you guys cough shall who wrote in
the same as a youtuber which youtuber do
you model success so my youtube channel
is called modeling the Masters I'm
obviously a huge fan of modeling success
and there are three main people that I
model a lot on my youtube channel that
I'm going to talk about today so number
one is Gary Vaynerchuk I've been a big
fan of the Gary B show since he started
it and I don't know that I model so much
his technique for the most part is just
sitting in his office although it does
change up every now and then but what I
love about him is he is unafraid to be
himself he'll say things that might be
controversial that he strongly believes
in and he's not afraid to voice those
opinions and so I try to bring some of
that to my channel I recommend if you're
an entrepreneur you should check out his
channel he's a little brash and abrasive
and swears and might put you off but he
has a lot of great information valuing
knowledge I think will help you if you
can look past that initial bravado that
may come off as being massively
egotistical there's a lot of great
knowledge in their number two is kissing
nice dad and he runs a daily vlog on his
channel that most of the videos will get
hundreds of thousands of views and what
I learned from him are two things one I
loved how he does everything himself he
films everything himself and he doesn't
just take the camera and pointed out
himself to put it on top of garbage cans
and street signs and any way they can
get another angle of himself to make it
more interesting he does the other thing
I really like about him is that he also
is not afraid of being himself and
doesn't care what people think and so
when he's on the street filming people
will be watching him and I remember when
I was first starting to fill myself
outside with people around I was nervous
and I wasn't being myself and just
watching him do it gave me a lot more
courage and confidence it's a daily vlog
so it's hard to keep on top of i find so
i'm behind on his videos compared to
gary's who watch all of but every time i
do i get new ideas and inspiration to
make much
better and number three is tim schmoyer
and what i get from tim is all of these
strategies tips techniques to be better
on youtube I don't pretend to be the
world's greatest YouTube expert Tim
knows a lot more about things than I do
about SEO and about using end cards and
using the other cards and how to name
things and so anytime there's news about
youtube and ideas on how to grow my
channel I get a lot of those ideas from
Tim and so he's got an amazing channel
that will link up and if you want to
grow your YouTube channel I definitely
recommend subscribing use another one
where I watch every single video that it
comes up with and it's almost always
amazing value for me so those are the
three channels that i model the most and
i'm curious to find out who are the
youtubers that you model most leave it
in the comments below i'm really curious
to find out thank you guys so much for
watching if you need to believe and i'll
see you soon